[Musique]
la france était le raciste selon jamel
debbouze la réponse est non il ya du
racisme en france mais la france n'est
pas raciste une interview donnée au
monde l'humoriste est revenu sur les
scores du rassemblement national aux
dernières élections aujourd'hui je
considère que ce n'est pas un vrai front
national c'est un fond de la misère le
score du front national c'est un score
de gens qui n'arrivent pas à joindre les
deux bouts pour lui ce vote est devenu
un vote de contestation contre la
politique d' emmanuel macron mais il
n'imagine pas une seconde que les
français sont racistes si la france
était raciste cela fait belle lurette qu
on serait tous dehors pour lui la france
lui a tout donné il reconnaît
qu'aujourd'hui certains jeunes ne sont
pas conscients de la chance qu'ils ont
je sens une scission car certains jeunes
d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas eu la même
histoire que moi avec la france et ça
c'est dommage alors selon jamel debbouze
la france n'est pas raciste at il raison
de parler politique
son discours est plutôt explique
honorable voilà une très honorable alors
il ya un seul il ya deux noms mais c'est
et c'est dingue c'est lorsque j'en fais
partie alors que chez la personne un
petit peu plus grand sérieux quand même
bon allez donc vous dites nous non non
la france ne paraît bien je suis plutôt
d'accord avec jamel debbouze il y a
beaucoup de racisme et de raciste en
france la maison s'est dit d'accord avec
lui non à ben oui je suis d'accord avec
toi
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle me toi pas fait un retour qu'il
fasse pas un départ très vite we are
donc il ya plus de dix ans alors il a
fallu donc non on n'est pas d'accord
avec lui mais non pas sur moi j'ai un
peu du mal avec cette vision un peu
idyllique on peut quand même dire que
jamel debbouze il n'est venu quand même
pas dans le milieu de monsieur et madame
tout le monde
jamais deux fils arrêté par la police en
lui demandant c'est le fils ou un
autographe on ne lui a pas dit non je
suis pas sûr aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
pense que la vie sa vison est un peu
tronqué pour le togo chance alors vous
donc vous pensez super jusqu'au bout de
la fa bertrand des cas ce que vous
pensez que des français sont racistes
[Musique]
une malouine assiste le front national
serait passé le front national n'est pas
passer ça prouve bien qu'il ya quand
même une hausse assez chiant
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de ce que tu dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais chose près alors oui évidemment que
la france elle est raciste aujourd'hui
vous perte est clairement pas que les
mêmes avantages dans la vie quand vous
appelez jean-charles donc on vous
appelez mohammed duma c'est vrai il ya
du racisme à l'école ya du racisme à
l'embauché du racisme au logement dans
les restaurants dans les boîtes de nuit
partout donc aisé évidemment que la
français est raciste et c'est déconnecté
des réalités que de dire ça évidemment
comme le dit bertrand peut-être que lui
aujourd'hui il a la chance d'avoir une
de mener une vie où il n'est pas
confronté à ça mais la réalité on le
voit tous les jours enfin j'veux dire
partout partout c'est un modèle pour
notre jeune et pour beaucoup de jeunes
de banlieue il a un discours positif
c'est très bien mais ça n'avance pas sur
le sort sur son sort d'ailleurs et sur
le sort des autres
le message est plutôt bon mais le
message il est très bon mais c'est
l'inversé le monde des bisounours c'est
la question qu'on lui impose le racisme
il est partout regarder les dossiers de
deux pour des locations d'appartements
qui sont refusés les gens qui se font
refouler par tous parce qu'ils sont ils
ont aidé yann est à l'origine et le
racisme il est partout partout
il ya du raffinement
français que les français oui mais
effectivement
énorme hénart un peu partout mais il ya
effectivement des gens en france qui
sont racistes maintenant est ce que les
français sont racistes non et je trouve
que ce qui est en train de faire c'est
formidable parce que leader de l'espoir
à aussi à tout le monde il faut arrêter
en permanence de dire qu' on est tous le
monde est raciste machin il ya quand
même des gens qui ne sont pas racistes
dans sûr il ya du racisme mais les
français d'enfants sans bien sûr comme
ça que ça aussi
s'il n'avait pas la carrière qu'il a
mais il vient de tram
difficiles dans sa vie maintenant
un
maillage tempère positif ce qui la fait
jamais au niveau du fond au niveau de la
forme est effectivement ce qui s'est
passé lors de ces présidentielles c'est
tout simplement du vote de contestation
de ras-le-bol de gens déçus et tout donc
la conclusion est très bonne et je
trouve qu'il a très bien il est clair
que l'écart entre % de personnes qui ont
voté fn racistes
c'est d'aller aux mêmes anti-marine le
ballon d'eau douce et est ce que dans en
belgique vous excuser belle france qui
sont plus ou moins c'est ce que les
français nous quelle
véritable problème avec la politique
puisque c'est très compliqué en belgique
on est divisés c'est ce qu'on appelle un
état fédéral on est divisé en communauté
dévoilons le oui absolument et alors
nous vraiment le groupe notre gros
problème c'est que la partie nord ne
supporte pas la partie sud c'est à dire
que la flandre ne supporte pas la
wallonie ceux qui parlent le néerlandais
ne supporte pas ceux qui parlent le
français parce qu'il ya un problème
d'économie et que le pays est vraiment
scindée en deux et que les belges
trouvent que les français sont racistes
oui on a suivi avec beaucoup d'intérêt
en tout cas les élections
présidentielles en étant en effet
surpris voire estomaqué en effet delà du
duel qui s'est jouée entre manuel macro
et marine le pen où ils sont fréquents